i
[Música]
ah
mientras avanza la campaña de vacunación
contra el kobe 19 aquí en el reino
unido- un estudio del imperial college
of london arrojó que la población
británica es la que está más dispuesta a
vacunarse contra este virus en un 78%
el estudio realizado en 15 países arrojó
además que en febrero creció la
proporción de personas que quiere
vacunarse en un 40 por ciento lo cierto
es que la vacunación en este país avanza
bastante rápido ya 18 millones de
personas casi 18 de millones de personas
ha recibido la primera dosis de esta
vacuna ya han sido inmunizadas las
personas más vulnerables sobre los 80
años todos los profesionales del sistema
nacional de salud y ahora se está
vacunando a las personas sobre los 60
años
el primer ministro boris johnson ha
prometido que toda la población sobre
los 18 años habrá recibido a finales de
julio de este año una carta de
invitación para ser vacunado contra el
cob y 19
[Música]
entre los canadienses la confianza en la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 ha aumentado
en los últimos meses los datos del
imperio college london estiman que el
porcentaje de personas que están muy de
acuerdo con su vacunación inmediata ha
aumentado del 33 por ciento a mediados
de noviembre a casi el 50% en enero pero
muchos canadienses han comenzado a
perder la confianza en sus posibilidades
de acceso según la encuestadora en with
el gobierno federal ha ordenado más
dosis de vacunas per cápita que
cualquier otro país del mundo pero los
retrasos en los envíos desde europa han
sembrado dudas y reducir las tasas de
vacunación menos del 3% de los
canadienses ha recibido su primera dosis
y menos del 1 por ciento ha recibido las
dos dosis requeridas aunque nuevos
acuerdos podrían acelerar este ritmo el
ceip país también cuenta con población
escéptica de las vacunas
el estudio del imperial college encontró
que poco más de una quinta parte de los
canadienses no recibirán una dosis ahora
bajo ningún motivo
[Música]
las últimas encuestas indican que el 70%
de los surcoreanos está a favor de
ponerse pronto la vacuna contra la cob y
19 lo que implica un incremento de casi
el 10% con respecto a hace 2 meses este
cambio de tendencia responde
principalmente al hecho de que con el
sur aún no ha iniciado su campaña de
vacunación ya que los ciudadanos del
país asiático han podido ir viendo cómo
otros países empezaban a vacunar sin
reportar efectos secundarios importantes
para la salud corea del sur tiene
previsto iniciar su campaña de
vacunación el próximo 26 de febrero y
los primeros en recibir en las
inoculaciones serán sanitarios que
trabajan a diario con pacientes de kobe
19 y residentes en centros de mayores a
partir de marzo seguirán los mayores de
65 años y el resto de sanitarios antes
de iniciar la última fase de vacunación
en junio con vistas a que el país
asiático alcance la llamada inmunidad de
rebaño en noviembre
[Música]